all right welcome back to episode 2 we
had some technical issues
I accidentally accidentally delete in my
heart all right so we're in a new world
but that's okay stop stalking me with
that face it is so much um yeah so let's
be more quick this time ap babe can't
even do that voice Pig
what the [ __ ] is that what the [ __ ] what
it's a pumpkin oh my god what the [ __ ]
is that you can use it as a helmet what
the [ __ ] you should as a helmet this
isn't even Halloween anymore
use it as a helmet oh my god listen Oy
is oh [ __ ] this place was pretty neat
yeah Wow it's like a sanctuary
let's build her yeah we should how the
[ __ ] do I get down though
jump down with me but don't kill
yourself no 360 oh those sound tiny
flower oh wait the sound is completely
off I forgot that oh no there we go
when I hear the chickens of course Paige
again
like they I can hit this chicken
indestructible chicken there you are
[ __ ] you shaking should be like a roof
over this no because then it would be
dark huh I don't know let's clear out
this area
why hasn't or just done what I don't
really need torches ease wait a minute
so huzzah
to say so I'm the boss
oh really know who made who put you in
charge you get it thank you
yes I'd take that burn as er this out
all right we got a football field here
or something I don't know what we should
be there but ah beautiful stars ah oh
sorry
get the door and then you just came up
oh I hate that I can't use those words
when you're around I know you love it
no I [ __ ] in it the door why do you
have to place the door there it should
be no leave it alone no I'm not leaving
the door alone no living the lump leave
the door alone what should be here
I cut me and it's there we go I'm just
gonna place the block on that then let's
poke [ __ ] get your ass in here
think we're safe though I don't want to
get raped by you
we are the chicken though
but the pumpkin should be outside I
think
then place the dots on it's not an
inside interior but the [ __ ] did it go
though did you pass out yeah the stove
uh-huh stir this oh hi - it's pretty
neat yeah that we know it's yeah
oh it is no no let's do this I'm going
to go check something right
oh oh I say skeletal Fred run run run
run run run run run run run work listen
know the pumpkin how do I place it in
the wrong direction
oh yeah you place the direction you want
it to how the flavor I do that I can do
it for you I don't want to know how you
do it just yump yump I love that look
they're about cat dammit
oh well the pleasure well if you place
it down here it's gonna face you
hmm - chicken no no no he's our buddy
ah you kill them you [ __ ] oh hey
leg one leg oh ow dude [ __ ]
Oh getting into skele-toes hello this is
whoa hey then fine let's find some coal
then oh hey let's all top yeah it's like
same time Rosa I put the call in the
purpose it's so annoying when you like
really really really want to find a no
it doesn't it you never seem to find it
and then they let it get me get a lot of
God
ah very nice very good they come back
more torches yeah oh that was you I was
like with Allah see sorry keep knowing
that you check and keep feeding each
other
I'm gonna cut your handsome I'm not an
[ __ ] let's do all your masks
all right I got one can you cooked egg
no you can't can you eat egg do torches
what's the point with the egg if you
can't do anything with it doctor gonna
make sure can cook yeah it will bake a
cake with I saw something like love on
the when I created it on singer players
of law on the on the ground yeah yeah
not changed it can spawn a random la
banda
I think I saw diamond but I wasn't sure
because I never seen that knowing you
know if you find a diamond it was some
sort of metal and I've never seen it
before they write a check it wasn't
bother enough to figure maybe it was
your face now with your face it said see
you guys on it dude stop doing that stop
being in my way so this is just gonna be
a long corridor yeah can build something
with glitter liner we should keep a 1
pole in here like a strip pole no look I
want one in do it with fences later
fans do I need a fence for a strip pole
yes
making sense we show you that so you
made a strip pole before that's what
you're saying no I knew it I [ __ ]
knew it had eat anyway ok I'm gonna show
you now
uh-huh so you just left me with the
other but oh dude no no I didn't for
okay so this is the stripper pole I like
okay yet I guess would you
all right people you just need BCC
lights and my bikini and we're good
a creep at the bikini I guess we say
that all later I could bring a bikini
that sounds pretty awesome actually
okay it stuck what it's light outside
hey dude arrow it's another one I'm dead
dead yet
you should make a sword so I can protect
myself oh my lord there's some military
penis I don't know if I remember the
military penis in the whorehouse I doubt
that oh that's a cool-looking Mountain
over there yes right of a lot surprise
so beautiful
creepers they blow your [ __ ] up
embrace everything you got - oh look
find you oh holy [ __ ] what is that oh
there's a creeper I seen I hope it dude
Oh creepy King oh